hey everyone I'm Abbi sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen the holidays are here
which pretty much translates to a full
month wine and cheese party and trust me
I will never turn down a good glass of
vino and a well curated cheese platter
but sometimes you want something a
little more substantial elegant and with
a little less cheese but still some
cheese guys I'm not getting rid of all
cheese
so I've parted with my friends at corvy
spirit and wines to bring you my four
favorite holiday appetizers to pair with
my four favorite wines let's get started
first up my cherry and caramelized onion
bruschetta I love pairing this with a
Campo Viejo reserva thanks to its
complementary flavors of bold cherry
plum blackberry and peppery vanilla oh
my god it's really good
first I brush slices of whole-grain
baguette with a touch of olive oil and
fleur de sel and bake at 400 until
golden brown next i saute a sweet onion
low and slow until caramelized in a
touch of olive oil before adding in my
sweet cherries honey balsamic vinegar
and a pinch of salt and pepper and of
course the red wine simmer until the
cherries break down and the mixture
looks jammy when it's time to serve I
lay a few thin slices of black plums
onto the toasts top it with some cherry
jam sprinkled on with the crushed
pistachios and finish with a few
shavings of Parmesan cheese
next is my mushroom and ricotta
bruschetta I love pairing this with a
reserve Chardonnay like this one from
Jacobs Creek because it has a nice
creamy texture and I love that the white
peach flavor and the wine really
complements the light ricotta cheese but
it still lets those tasty mushrooms
shine just heat a teaspoon of oil in a
skillet and saute some mushrooms until
golden brown add in the garlic and thyme
leaves and stir for 30 seconds then pour
in the Chardonnay and a pinch of salt
and pepper and simmer until little
liquid evaporates next I smear my toast
with some part skim ricotta cheese top
with some lemon zest add my sauteed
mushrooms and garnish with some fresh
parsley third let's try my Maine Shango
stuffed prosciutto wrapped date these
babies are addictive and so good with a
Cabernet like this one by Buried hope
this wine has a light blackcurrant and
plum flavor that is really yummy with
the sweet dates and I love the tannins
help cut the richness of the prosciutto
and cheese first place a small piece of
manchego cheese into the cavity of a
pitted date before wrapping it a small
piece of prosciutto
they cut 350 degrees for 12 minutes or
until the bacon crisps up and the cheese
begins to gently melt meanwhile I simmer
half a cup of Cabernet in a touch of
honey until reduced to a thick sweet
syrup toss the wrapped dates in the
sauce and serve warm and finally let's
try my poached pear and almond goat's
cheese skewers I love this recipe with a
Sauvignon Blanc like this one by Stone
Lee because the fresh acidity really
stands up well to the tankiness of the
goat's cheese and the passion fruit
flavors of the wine pear nice
with the fruitiness of the pair into a
small saucepan I put the white wine
water honey lemon rind lemon juice
peppercorns in a cinnamon stick and I
simmer until the honey dissolves then I
add in some balls of pears that I cut
with a melon baller and simmer the
mixture until slightly soft but not
falling apart meanwhile I've roll some
reduced fat goat cheese into some small
balls for tossing them in the toasted
sliced almonds and mince dried
cranberries and I fastened a pair ball
and a goat's cheese ball onto some small
toothpicks and enjoy see it tell me that
is not a serious upgrade from your
traditional cheese and crackers with
wine and appetizer pairings like this
you're probably gonna be tough tuned to
hosting a lot more parties come the new
year thanks so much for watching guys
for more healthy holiday ideas and
recipes be sure to subscribe to my
channel and I'll see you next time on
copy's kitchen